so as part of the lead up to Marvel's
Civil War - what I want to do here is
begin by focusing on individual
characters and teams who will play a
role in the events starting with Captain
Marvel and what I'm hoping is that in
addition to my existing videos on our
character prior to Secret Wars this
video will serve to establish how she
has evolved in both the Secret Wars and
post Secret Wars landscape of Marvel
Comics
so like most of my all-new all-different
lineup understanding of carol danvers
within the new mafia crime landscape
resides in the pre Secret Wars
rebranding of Marvel now while we can't
speculate on whether or not Secret Wars
was originally designed to be a reboot
and scrapped during the planning process
for the most part the comic community
agrees on the idea that with virtually
all stories and events within Marvel
comics laying the foundation for the
Secret Wars event itself Marvel now fell
in line with this idea by seeing a
shake-up of Marvel's line reworking
various characters and teams who in turn
would be featured in the Marvel prime
universe using the novel now platform
written by Kelly sue Taconic with art
from David Lopez because the life of
Carol Danvers on reviewing the original
Captain Marvel is a hero to look up to
in addition to being an ally on several
occasions since the title had officially
been vacated following his death in 1984
his classic story by jim Starlin captain
marvel vol 7 & 8 were launched in 2012
and 2014 and centered on Carol Danvers
stepping into that role initially
presented to her by Steve Rogers due to
her various escapades over the life of
her career since the development of her
powers
Carol's feelings unofficially adopted
the mantle of Captain Marvel came with a
bit of trepidation to sidetrack for a
second within marvel comics the original
Captain Marvel was named marvel and
hailed from the Kree Empire but turned
traitor and allied himself with Earth's
heroes against the Kree the accuser
Corps who acted as the main
law-enforcement body as well as the Kree
leader the supreme intelligence a
massive computer composed of the most
gifted minds of the Kree race as well as
his past leaders while Marvel
experiences own waxes and wanes in terms
of popularity among readers on the whole
he functioned as a kind of universal
protector appointed to that position by
E on one of the cosmic entities who
serves to protect the life energies of
the universe with Captain Marvel coming
into conflict like Thanos and allowing
Marvel comics to expand on their overall
cosmic landscape where his death in 1984
saw the position empty with no one
taking its place
within the Marvel Universe this was both
a sign of respect due to his legacy in
terms of Captain Marvel's involvement in
the lives of almost all of the earth
sphero's as well as the idea that no one
had ever really elected to take his
place that said for Carol Danvers the
development of her powers in exposure to
the superhero community came after
witness
a battle between Marvel and his former
superior yah drug coming along as part
of Marvel's journey and taking sides
against the Kree the battle between the
two occurred in Cape Canaveral which
housed several nuclear weapons orgy on
Raw infinity use as a means to wipe out
humanity with Carroll station as a
member of the United States Air Force
during the conflict she had been exposed
to a machine called the site magnetron a
device not unlike the Cosmic Cube and
that had granted the wishes of its user
by altering matter and energy enamored
with the bravery and power of Marvel and
his desire to protect humanity during
the battle Danvers was exposed to this
like magnetron by accident while
simultaneously wishing to become an
equal to Marvel now where Carroll's
publications would go on to see her
endowed with the powers of superhuman
strength speed stamina durability and
flight as well as energy absorption and
projection up until the time of his
death and after Marvel always functioned
as Danvers idol and her attempt to carve
out her own niche within a superhero
community to this end much like the
original Marvel who crossed paths with
both earthbound and spacefaring heroes
under the writing of the conic volumes 7
saw Danvers crossing over with a
veritable who's who of the universe
including Iron Man the guardians of the
galaxy and Jason of spartax the leader
of the sure toy Empire and father to
Peter quill using this to establish
peril as a de facto protector of the
universe even if only due to
circumstance after strange several
issues thinking over the idea Danvers
eventually agreed that as someone who
had developed her powers in response to
Marvel and spent a large portion of her
life looking to him as a role model it
made sense to tap into the legacy and
become the next hero to dawn the mantle
of Captain Marvel continuing on for the
next several years and into the realm of
Marvel now which served to refresh
various teams and characters with new
number ones new riders and new artists
for struggling titles because Danvers
comic had been regularly performing in
the top 20 of Marvel's releases there
was no real reason to change the formula
meaning that Kelly C Taconic remained on
his rider and continued her expansion on
Carol Danvers role within the Marvel
Universe
now having said all of that were to kind
of continue the solo and team up
Adventures of Danvers within the pages
of a road series writer Jonathan Hickman
had been in the process of leading up to
suger wars during his time on Avengers
and New Avengers for this initially
presented questions in terms of how
Danvers continuity fit into the ongoing
events due to her being off planet for
the entirety of the conex from marvel
solved this question by Jimmy the
Avengers and New Avengers stories
forward by eight months with issues 35
and 24 respectively while maintaining
the continuity of Danvers and other
titles what this meant was that where
Captain Marvel volume 8 did run until
2015 with the cancellation of all titles
and the start of all-new all-different
marvel herstory like all others outside
of the events within Avengers and New
Avengers and last days all took place
within the eight month window now with
the main Secret Wars events unfolding
with Reed Richards Black Panthers
fireman and others working the over
through a dooms new world and set things
back to rights Marvel initiated a series
of ancillary tie-ins that both provided
a depiction of various characters and
events from alternate realities but also
experimented with the existing heroes
using fan reception as a gauge for the
post Secret Wars landscape with the
Connick returning for the self-contained
four-part miniseries because her work
had elevated Carole to being the
headliner of Marvel's female led titles
and teams Danvers was provided her own
group in the form of the Carroll Corps
with the publication acting as a tribute
to the Past while looking to the future
but also reworking existing teams with a
pre Secret Wars line since the original
publications of Danvers had her rooted
in the air force and maintaining ties to
the military even after the introduction
of her powers Taconic ruled this over by
having the Carroll core function as an
elite fighter squadron at the same time
with Danvers Kamala Khan Black Widow and
the inhuman Queen Medusa blazing the
trail for popular powerful and capable
women in comics young female readers had
absolutely fallen in love with the work
of the conic and the leadership
capabilities of Danvers
as a result and in order to maintain the
existing audience base as well as
provide new content that could be used
following the conclusion of Ceuta Wars
the Carroll Corps was established as a
multi-cultural team of women not a focus
on this for a second since this group
will serve as part of all-new
all-different marvel the Carroll Corps
in and of themselves were actually a
reworked version
of a previously existing team called the
Banshee squadron created by the Connick
and Captain Marvel issue number two the
banshees were more akin to Nick Fury's
old Howling Commandos with the Connick
refer to them as such and that each
member of the team had their own
personalities and unique traits which
make them relatable to young women take
it from the comics website Jerry is a
Nick Fury analog in that she has dark
hair piled high on her head and a beauty
mark on her face like Marilyn Monroe or
Sidney Crawford
Mackey is the dum-dum Dugan analog in
that like the iconic hero she is a
redhead with a fiery personality and the
right hand of Jerry moving to be as she
was designed to be the all-american girl
hailing from a French mother in a
Japanese father and represents Dino
Minnelli Daisy diddle represents
Reverend due to her petite blond form
but also sporting the same ground rifle
with rifka being the easy Kohan analog
now where Captain Marvel in the Carroll
core focused heavily on Carol Danvers
exploring the world around them while
running into opposition from the
forecourt who served as dooms police and
fortune the boundaries of battle world
fighter Kelly sue Taconic was actually
on her way out covered in an article
published by the Mary Sue a geek culture
hub for movies television video games
technology and comics while Tektronix
work had placed significant emphasis on
Danvers character allowing her
personality leadership capabilities and
strength as a woman to take precedent
over her powers with the announcement of
a Captain Marvel film slated for 2018
the Connick had resonated that the film
would likely draw from the all-new
all-different mobile landscape or at
least some portion of it coming to the
conclusion that she would likely have to
stay on as writer for several more years
Taconic vacated her position in order to
focus on personal projects including
planet pretty deadly and the
television adaptation of Matt Fraction
sex criminals coming out of the control
of Tara butters a writer and producer
for shows like agent Carter Hawaii
five-o and dollhouse as well as Law &
Order Special Victims Unit
the newly launched Captain model volume
9 saw Carol Danvers taking over as
director of sward to sidetrack here
during his run on astonishing x-men in
addition to some of the character
changes made to the x-men roster proper
including the return of Colossus writer
Joss Whedon had introduced the sentient
world observation and response
department
coming out of Earth experiencing various
invasions and conflicts with
extraterrestrial races
unlike Armour which focuses on alternate
realities and shield which focus on
threats within the earth sword observes
and analyzes all phases in the universe
determining the threat level and
cataloging them for future reference
originally led by Abigail brand a mutant
alien hybrid who possessed the power to
burn objects on contact as well as
reshaping their tongue allowing her to
speak any alien language because
although all-different marvel was
designed to shake up the status quo if
not reboot like most of models landscape
sword saw wholesale reworking with
Abigail brand acting as the counterpart
to Nick Fury within sword these duties
were handed over to Carol Danvers within
the main cap of novel publications
allowing Terra butters to shift Abigail
brand down to second in command while
fleshing out Danvers character and
explore her relationship to the original
Captain Marvel was only around for
issues in so far the events unfolded by
seeing sword maintaining a traditional
role of monitoring extraterrestrial
threats while also consisting of the
Alpha flight squadron where the group
was previously associated with Canada as
a government-sanctioned superhero team
not unlike the second iteration of
x-factor the problem faced by Marvel was
that Alpha Flight was only viewed as a
poor man's x-men when they had tried to
boost popularity for the grew by
incorporating crossovers with both lame
on the whole a slide for main
recognition alpha flight solo series
always performed poorly for the very few
readers taking them seriously looking to
rectify this problem under Tara butters
alpha flight was rolled in as a kind of
elite task force for sword helping to
carry out both reconnaissance and strike
missions that fell in line with swords
Charter now having said all of that
while I will have a video proper on the
ultimate Steam especially now that
galactus is being used as a means to
explore the all-new all-different
universe and answer our questions and
terms of the continuities while Carol
Danvers is the front runner within her
own solo series and the all-new
all-different Ultimates she's more of a
sight alone character because the
Ultimates exist as a version of the
Avengers team focusing on problems that
threaten the Marvel crown universe as a
whole the team fit perfectly in line
with the new Carol Danvers allowing her
to use the resources of swords to
complement the intelligence of Black
Panther MD Marvel as well as a universal
powers of Monica Rambeau
in America Chavez while The Ultimates
themselves would go on
formed Galactus from the devourer of
worlds to light bringer as well as form
a cosmic cube and witnessed the return
of Thanos these are topics that I want
to save for the Ultimates video since
the actions of their team will serve as
a catalyst for the events of Civil War 2
and the conflict between Iron Man and
Carol Danvers with that being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys later please